why did we stop going to the Moon don't
get me started you don't uh I'd like to
start you up let the record show you
started this now the second word of the
title of your podcast is intense so
let's go there we were last on the moon
51 years ago that's half a century
there's more technology in a happy
birthday greeting card that you open up
and sings Happy Birthday to you then
went to the moon we had Apollo 18 ready
to fly then we oh wait a minute Rush's
not going to the Moon well I guess we
don't need to go to the Moon then
because that's why we went we tell
ourselves oh we're Americans and
explorers we were scared witless that
the Godless communist Soviet Union would
beat us to me it feels like we need to
get there cuz we're like defending the
moon but what are they defending what is
on the dark
side secret mineral deposits maybe you
can mine the moon
right